o se cumple un año desde que usan
ordenar a su confinamiento una medida
sin precedentes y que fue recibida por
el mundo con críticas de escepticismo
pero que poco después tuvo que replicar
los once millones de ugandeses tuvieron
que permanecer durante 76 días
encerrados en sus casas sin posibilidad
de pisar la calle bajo ninguna excusa
porque una red extensa de funcionarios y
voluntarios les llevaban la comida y
todo lo que pudieran necesitar o johan
cumple ocho meses sin contagios locales
y disfruta de algo muy parecido a la
vieja normalidad con bares y
restaurantes llenos aquí se dice que
esta es la ciudad más segura de china y
que además cuentan con experiencia así
que si el virus reaparece sabrán cómo
vencerlo de nuevo y sin embargo nadie
baja la guardia aquí todo el mundo lleva
mascarillas y en los locales siguen
pidiendo el código verde en el teléfono
no preocupa ahora a wuhan sino el brote
localizado en pekín y las provincias
limítrofes es el más grave de los
últimos meses y está poniendo en peligro
la celebración
vacaciones de año nuevo